And so Pinocchio was left without the
guidance of conscience and the cricket
is trying to figure out how to get off
pleasure island back.
He goes through the gates and he sees
what's actually going on and what's
going on is that the coach when has this
like slave boat down in the bowels of
the island and he's got all these,
these black suited minions with the
glowing eyes working for him and they're
rounding up what looked like donkeys.
And so they're are beasts of burden,
right?
And so there's an idea here that if you
produce,
if you pursue impulsive pleasure to the
detriment of the development of your
character,
you're going to end up a beast of
burden.
You're going to end up a slave to a
tyrant.
And that's exactly right.
And so anyways,
put other cricket doesn't.
You can see one of those black suited
horrors here,
hauling donkeys out of this crate and
one of them has a hat on and they look
very sad and they're in different
crates.
And one of them says sold to the salt
mines.
And one says sold to the circus.
And so they're shipped off to be,
to be slaves,
roughly speaking,
and they look very sad and then one of
them gets hauled out of a crate and he's
still got a hat.
He has a hat on and a sweater and he can
still talk.
He's a boy.
It turns out that's been half
transformed into a jackass,
abrading jackass prior to being
enslaved.
And so that's,
that's another thing that's quite
interesting about the story.
You know,
it,
it also makes the case that if you
replace your voice with stupid brain,
that the probability that you're going
to become enslaved by a tyrant is
extraordinarily high.
And I always can't help but think about
idiot idiot logs in that manner.
You know,
Solzhenitsyn wrote about the radical
left ideologues that got thrown in the
Gulag archipelago,
you know,
so they were part party stalwarts.
This happened to a lot of people,
true believers who are vacuumed up by
the in this machine and thrown in,
thrown into the ghoulag anyways.
And he said that those people suffered
in some ways more than everyone else
because what did he say?
They were bit by the beloved hand that
fed them and so the first while when
they were in the camps,
socialism really didn't know what to do
with people like that because on the one
hand while they were in the camps and
wasn't that awful and they'd been torn
away from their families and you know,
stripped of all their identity and their
status and so that's pretty rough.
But on another hand they were writing
letters,
protesting their innocence and assuming
that everyone else in the camp was
guilty but they were innocent and they
were still strident believers in the
communist process.
And so,
you know,
it was a conundrum.
Here they are being terribly punished,
but by the same token,
there are also.
The perpetrators have their own demise.
So how do you deal with them?
And they used to play comrades.
He said they used to play comrades with
people like that and invite them into an
ideological discussion about the camp
situation and the situation in the
country as a whole and let them rattle
out their idiot logical justifications
for everything that had happened in,
in trying to make them parody
themselves.
Roughly speaking,
it was a rough game and Solzhenitsyn
also concluded that
there is no helping someone like that
when they were still ensconced inside
that brain ideology.
You can predict everything they were
going to say.
It's like someone had a crank,
you could just crank it and out would
come the proper radiological formulas,
but then he realized that as soon as
they,
let's call it,
repented of that and started to realize
their own role in it or the era of the
system,
then he would start communicating with
them.
You know,
as if they were people who who you could
communicate with.
Yeah,
so that was very interesting as far as
I'm concerned.
Anyways,
this kid is still a little bit human.
He starts to cry for his mom and the
coachman basically throws them back into
the crate and says that he's not ready
yet,
and the reason for that is that he could
still.
He still had the power of independent
speech.
You remember right at the beginning of
the movie when the Mouse was painted on
Pinocchio,
we saw that mask that was really glaring
at the process and I said that character
recurs continually throughout the movie.
And here's a good example of that
because the coach,
when is the enemy of anything that has
its own voice.
So he's the anti Japan.
Oh,
that's a good way of thinking about it.
He's the tyrannical aspect of the,
of the culture,
but as in so far as one of these mostly
donkeys,
mostly jackasses can still talk.
Then they're not completely fit for
slavery.
And you remember this movie was being
made at about the same time that the
Nazi transformation of Germany was
taking place.
And so all these terrible underground
things,
you know this,
this process whereby people were being
reduced to two ideological slave say and
in this terrible process that was all
playing out in Europe in a very big way.
And it's not like people weren't aware
of that,
you know,
it was in there.
So
any ways that the donkey's,
the Jack asses that can still talk,
her crying and complaining and repenting
and the coachman turns into a full Kyron
again in cracks the whip,
if I remember correctly,
and says you've had your fun and now
you're going to pay for it.
So the cricket gets word of all this.
He gets wind of it.
He starts to understand what's happened
is that all these bad kids were enticed
out onto this island so that they could
be enslaved.
And he's really taken aback by that to
say the least.
But he realizes what's going on.
So He runs back to find Pinocchio.
And then the scene switches back to the
eight ball bar where I'm lamp wick is
drinking beer and complaining about what
the conscience said,
you know,
cause he's kind of guilty,
I'm ashamed,
but he won't admit it because he doesn't
admit he knows everything.
He's not going to admit anything about
himself that isn't perfect.
He's a real totalitarian in training and
he drinks this beer and he's laughing
about the conscious and putting them
down.
And then he says,
well,
what?
What is,
what does he say?
Exactly?
What does he think?
I am a jack ass or something like that.
Maybe that's not the words.
Exactly.
And then he grows these,
these ears from Pinocchio,
sees that and immediately takes a look
at the beer and stops drinking it.
And then land put transformers one more
time and his face turns into the face of
a donkey.
And he's laughing still.
And then his,
his hands.
Oh yes.
He laughs suddenly starts to bray like
a,
like a jackass.
And he's horrified by that.
And then Pinocchio laughs and the brain
comes out as well.
And so now they're absolutely horrified
and lampock actually figures out what's
going on.
He figures out that he's been tricked
and that he's transforming and he's
completely horrified by it.
He becomes conscious of what's happening
to them.
And there's one particularly I would
say,
dramatic scene where his hands have
transformed in hooves and he's kicking
in and,
and,
and a leaping around the room and panic
and he comes up to a mirror and sees
himself as a Jack Ass.
And then he turns around and breaks the
mirror.
And so,
you know,
he self conscious for a moment.
Then he destroys his capacity for self
consciousness that he transforms
entirely into a jackass.
He's farther down the road than
Pinocchio.
And he comes crawling to Pinocchio to
save him and asks that the conscience
comes back so that he can get out of
this.
But of course it's a bit too late.
And so then UN occhio grows jackass ears
and he's absolutely terrified by it as
well.
He knows what's coming and the cricut
comes back and,
and guides them off.
Pleasure island.
And so then they end up on a cliff,
because this is an island after all,
they have to jump into the unknown,
right out of this impulsive adolescent
hedonic playground into the unknown.
And that's how they escape.